Hi, Dad.
Hey, kiddo.
Oh, my gosh,
do you look beautiful.
Cliff... how's your mom's hip?
-Good, thanks.
-Good.
He thinks you're my girlfriend.
Right.
Been busy?
Yeah.
Dean's travelling
with clients all the time,
and I'm just the buzzkill
waiting to schedule things.
I'm just, I'm so... stuck.
So Dean's going away a lot, huh?
On business trips?
Dad.
Raise your hand
if that sounds fishy.
He is not like you.
He's a good guy,
a great dad.
Sure. It's nature.
Males are forced to fight,
to dominate,
and to impregnate
all females.
Hmm.
Maybe he's just not
interested in me anymore.
Impossible.
A woman is at her most beautiful
between the ages of 35 and 39.
Great, so I have
many months left.
Felix, you're back in town.
Been busy?
Yeah, got a lot going on.
Do ya?
He should be worshipping
the ground you walk on.
And if he's doing
something dishonorable,
you need to know.
What if Dean's just busy?
I'm in a rut.
That's it.
I think we should follow him.
What?
I think you better see him in action.
This is your idea of incognito?
Coming through.
Here's the plaza.
This is the place they have an affair.
It has the most exits.
Exits on three streets.
Can you just act a little
less excited about this?
Because this is my life,
and it might be falling apart.
I don't know why women
get plastic surgery.
Because of men like you.
I prefer the factory original.
Yeah, and every other
make and model.
Thank you, I'm gonna
take that as a compliment.
Are there two?
Ho, ho... scared me.